use your price index it measures
inflation at the wholesale level what's
up 9.6
year-over-year as of november growing at
the fastest rate ever measured but don't
worry because the white house has a very
convenient scapegoat for rising prices
the president the secretary of
agriculture have both spoken to what
we've seen as the greed of meat
conglomerates the prices are higher that
is in his view
and the view of our secretary of
agriculture because of you could call it
corporate greed short
meet conglomerates senator tom cotton is
with us from from arkansas senator
cotton
i've heard a lot of things before
but now it's the meat conglomerates darn
it
yeah laura uh they're blaming everyone
for this record inflation when it just
goes back to democratic policies look
we've had this pandemic for two years we
didn't have record inflation in 2020. we
only had it in 2021 when the democrats
are in charge spending trillions of
dollars to make sure that there's more
money chasing fewer goods because of all
the lockdowns and the capacity
restrictions you still have in
democratic governed states first it was
oil and gas companies now it's meat
conglomerates maybe next week it's going
to be the elf on the shelf when there
aren't enough christmas presents under
the tree
oh the elf on the shelf did you have to
bring that up senator um okay so there
was a dnc holiday party tonight neither
of us happened to have been invited but
biden was there and he was feeling
pretty bold
we won as a unified democratic party
more unified than ever
now we look at 2022
i want to tell my republican friends get
ready bal you're going in for a problem
and we need to stay unified we have to
keep making the case and if we do i
believe we're going to win
senator last time i checked democrats
are having greater doubts about buying
than ever before independents they're
off the charts against uh biden's job
approval
so is he does he know a poll of
something about a poll we don't
the democrats are going to be unified in
a massive historic defeat next november
if they continue
to pursue this massive and reckless tax
and spending bill we just learned on
friday that if you eliminated all the
budget gimmicks it would be five
trillion dollars of spending laura three
trillion dollars of new deficit spending
it would do things like give amnesty to
illegal immigrants it would devastate
faith-based and family-based child care
it would implement major parts of the
green new deal to make it more expensive
to drive pickup trucks or suvs while
rich people are getting tax breaks to
buy electric vehicles
and of course it would continue to add
more fuel to the fire of inflation
that's hurting so many families
the american people spoke pretty clearly
last month in places like virginia and
new jersey long island minneapolis even
seattle and if the democrats don't wake
up and hear it they're going to face a
massive defeat next november now i
thought i had heard it all until tonight
on msnbc
where they tried to point out that the
real problem with biden's agenda
is they're not getting enough credit
from the media for all their
accomplishments
he literally has not seen a good
headline in i would say maybe six months
um and the reality also is the press is
simply covering biden the way his
opponents would want him to be covered
uh you know nothing positive that biden
has done has gotten any coverage
senator what positive has biden done
sorry but i actually was trying to think
of that today i couldn't think of much
well i'm sure msnbc's tens and tens of
viewers all across the country will
believe that but for the rest of us
it's just a matter of looking at the
scoreboard as they used to say in
football games i mean the scoreboard
doesn't lie look at the disastrous and
humiliating withdrawal from afghanistan
earlier this year or record inflation
you know in november joe biden said he
was going to do something after it was
announced we had record high inflation
in 30 years and he did in december we
now have 40-year record highs of
inflation or look at the crime wave that
continues to crash across the country
now you've got left-wing
looting mobs going out they first
rob from home depot all the crowbars and
the hammers and then they use those to
go rob the jewelry stores and
electronics stores the facts don't lie
joe biden and the democratic party this
year has have delivered failure after
failure after failure that's why the
american people aren't buying what the
democrats are selling senator i have to
ask you really quickly about liz cheney
and her off the wall obsession with text
messages to mark meadows i don't know if
you saw me earlier but i read all of my
tweets my public tweets that day january
6th they totally match what i said to
meadows and when i said at night but
she she's like a woman obsessed have you
checked on her lately have you
chatted with her on text message i want
to see your text messages senator
laura i did see what you said earlier in
the evening and i saw what sean hannity
said the same is true of brian kilmeade
uh you were apparently texting mark
meadows to encourage him to try to get
the violence under control that's
exactly what you and sean and brian and
so many of us said on january 6 that we
cannot tolerate any kind of rioting or
violence or chaos
that is these things same things that we
said throughout 2020 when you had left
wing blm mobs riding our streets and
looting and committing arson i don't
really understand the media's obsession
today with you and sean and brian and
others saying privately exactly what you
said publicly on january 6 of this year
senator thank you i appreciate it